yeah should we try and hook up your mom
and Kalin cat
I don't think kalons my mom's type hmm
what's your mom into black guys - no
she's strictly Vietnamese guys mom
doesn't like it I'm she doesn't she says
that all the time that's the only reason
why I'm with your dad is because I don't
like to try new things she that's safe
you have an honest family I like it
people are medically correct now there
Derek your dad there's two very honest I
don't think Koreans are politically
correct either right typically mmm
there's not about within the household
for sure
yeah there's protocol John I feel like
the flavor in your house is from your
you your mom and your sister your dad's
kind of just along for the ride that's
fair to say no my dad was a very very
wild man in his day oh yeah yeah he uh
without going into too much details he's
the type of guy to meet a girl at a
party a Mexican girl who is visiting
family from Mexico follow her to Mexico
without speaking a lick of English live
with her for a year come back after he
dumps her he's a romantic he's a real
romantic
you still like he likes to [ __ ] he's
also a romantic okay that's when you
fall in love for a year Oh move in for a
year and you follow a woman to another
country and you don't speak the language
you find that she was painfully hot I
would say balsam I follow a girl to
Syria right now she's hot of them yeah
that's true that'll happen like do you
know unsafe it is I'm like we'll figure
it out yeah don't worry there are
there's a certain type of hotness I will
follow to theory oh yeah you drive your
car cross-country for in the middle of
the night that's right it's it's all
worth it it's what drives you there you
go well goddamn that's her right now so
it's just like a flashback Friday [ __ ]
yeah Brian's are looking he's I like it
I have we here
what have we mama yeah she your mom's
her sister give me the miracle by the
way by the way this is my Wow what's her
real name ten this is my [ __ ] mom's
my egg by the way like T a n yeah
this would be my be my pickup line cat
good to see you and I don't believe you
introduced me to your sister Tiffany
that is it
oh that's all raised it'll be I thought
you're gonna have something for this no
no I took why I didn't do it right
cats so good to see you I don't believe
you've introduced me to your sister
Tiffany very good all right get her with
so much dad how are you it's so good to
see you mmm I don't believe you've
introduced me to your frame sister
it is your sister is it not Tiffany um
that's worse
so how my voice goes low though no it's
were Domini no I feel like you need to
do something too okay
Oh cat how are you who's the lady to
your left you ever take a ride in a
Tesla Oh who's duh who's your friend on
the left I need a few balut eggs for her
do you watch the Goldbergs hey and just
let me know if this would work on your
mom cat I got a few bluets at my house
what a balut and dick suck
what's a balut what is that what they
don't have a little nut you know what it
is but yeah blue ticks I raised my own
blood you want to stop hey you want to
stop you want to stop a bird from
hatching a couple weeks early what a
weed some bird feeders what say we get
that bird before cracks egg on its own
huh what say we kill that little thing
little innocent day hey I got an idea
I just [ __ ] I just hard-boiled a
bunch of birds that are about to hatch
how about we go
shehram open up together and you suck my
dick yeah you want to eat some pre
hatchling with a spoon
you want to stop it you want to kill a
bird in the egg and eat it with a spoon
how's that sound that turn you on is any
type of thing mama cat yeah he ended
bullets and then here's the other thing
I got a [ __ ] gallon of fruit punch as
well why don't we swallow that damn what
a wife wash it down turn it out want to
wash it down with some how about split a
baby bird and some fruit but well you
suck nothing I like more than
nothing like I like more than a blood
then I'm cutting some punch
I'm just throw three three things out
there mama cat Saturday night down the
fruit punch blue tag my dick ha ha ha
nothing I enjoy more that's that is that
not entitle my old friend brag I'll be
there
well friend I putting everyone Brian me
in the corner sipping a fresque and
jacking off that cool fresca
I think Russell Brand is a genuinely
good person though like he's gee I would
be his best friend right now I refuse
like a you're gonna brahma he's my
friend like Brian you get a text says
see you that's a guy to get on the
podcast sounds the famous man 1000 no
that's Russell Brand I'm talking about
John Mayer said recently and these are
all the women he's had he's been with
people that are famous that I've slept
with a lot of people know it should pop
up Jan if you type in a John Mayer mmm
it should be just in the news gets
recent reports 500 come on John hey John
I mean I'm come on bro yeah hey come on
bro you don't write your body is a
wonderland not [ __ ] the palaces hey
Brendon you you played John there and
I'm asking how many people you had sex
with them and then you give me your
answer and then I'll show you my
reaction John huge fan man love you bro
um you bet you you've bed some women
down would you do you have a number for
me pre writing your body's in Wonderland
or after I don't know man and maybe
total just off the top my head
yeah oh hey don't wanna know I'm sure
I'm gonna breath oh let me grab let me
grab my see cuz I know I mad about that
no I'm about to freak out this is gonna
be exciting I mean white-knuckle here
how many did Wilt Chamberlain do oh well
they saved northa ten thousand he was a
beast
I did five hundred give or take
hey Brendan John said he had sex with
500 he thinks that's a lot I feel like I
feel like John's just lying here I think
it's got to be more than that I slept
more than 500 but it says more than 500
people so right now I have heard around
the the Hollywood had a cooler that he
was eventually like dude I [ __ ] every
hot girl in the book why not try out
dudes really I don't know about that
happening on the guitar and got his dick
sucked I've never had that impulse I've
never liked when I was a young man I put
up some numbers and I never once was
like you know what a lot of girls this
past two weeks I needed dong yeah maybe
you're if you're John Mayer though you
know you're like God your body is a
wonderland he's like playing the guitar
like dude to me hos around here hey bro
seen him a couple times in person may
have the biggest head I've ever seen in
my life never seen a head saw Conan
O'Brien wants the two of them had on
Brian's head though my dad could fit you
could fiddle now John Mayer jump on
stage and do some stand-up with Dave
Chappelle which is kind of weird yeah
he's a PC he's friends with Doug
Davidoff he'll do some stand-up with him
John Merrow have fun in Arizona huh yeah
I hate the wagering that stupid Cup
mm-hmm get a gayer cup
I'm not going to it was fought in
Phoenix when they're good you wanted a
grand old time just a guy singing out
that's what that's just so much fun cuz
usually I'm on the road it's just me and
Jamie Jay have a great time but in the
green room was just with comments they
don't know there's you me re do big
chairs and hilarious
agent Justin was there's a good time
yeah man owner from zany's or Brian
Dorfman rind or from an owner of many
clubs it was a good time wasn't it yeah
a really good time just a bunch of guys
sitting there eating I think we're onto
something hey I did too you want to talk
about it well you didn't say what you
eat though are you talking about the we
time at the carne asada I hate I I
didn't just eat the carne asada then I
had I went double double down I doubled
down on the on the chili green chili
chicken and I ate two things of rice now
you got out
she my second show I was having some
trouble dude that green chilli I looked
at it and went you know I'm gonna try
out so I went you know what yeah I don't
feel like [ __ ] my pants in Phoenix right
believe this someone else and you found
it you practiced restraint well I did
yeah I went I double down I had two
giant meals and I wasn't hungry I'm not
I'm still not hungry yeah hungry
literally I haven't quite been right
since do that's a lot of food yes but I
think we're on with some of that show
we're not reinventing the wheel here now
by blue comet or dinner or the Kings of
Comedy
yep did it but I think that that's a
good formula to trickle in once a month
once every two months you do this kind
of all-star list of headliners four or
five guys you and I and friends you know
when I moved me CEO Andrew Santino Bobby
Lee
Ari Shaffir BJ we all do 25 everyone
does everyone does their work and then
we hang out maybe we were there for two
shows one night or two maybe we shoot
sunny antics backstage maybe we put that
up on YouTube I don't know we'll see
what happens called the big dick energy
tour big dick energy tour of power
clowns something like that fat dick dry
who has the energy of six men here's
what you don't want to do with me
you don't wanna give me eight hours of
sleep and give me two cups of coffee
because I'm ready to fight and run a
marathon at the same time that's a good
thing dude it's a very good thing let's
have erectile dysfunction yeah I'll show
you right now I gotta run
dude I've seen it with my own eyes thank
you now so I got that going for me the
thing is what's new for me is one ten
o'clock rolls around cuz daddy's getting
up early at 6:00 and stuff 10 o'clock
rolls around ready for bed
yeah Papa needs a nap around 4:00 p.m. I
shut it down kind of doesn't happen
sometimes for my son goes no not on my
watch yeah and then I'm usually if I'm
not doing sets late at night I'm in bed
at 9:00 sir well couples leave by 9:30
Oh a couple things that daddy's been
doing secretly you don't know about
number one [ __ ] dudes I called it
okay you knew it nope that's that's
something I thought I want to talk about
yeah that's something that when I was in
college I went through a phase now let's
do you want to leave private I'll leave
that private won't come out but
shut it down as you know I'll take
myself a twenty minute no longer 20
minute nap will shut it down power yeah
and there's an app called waking up by
Sam Harris
it's about meditation it's guided
meditation I may or may not have been
doing that for the past 45 days and if I
seem unusually centered if I seem like
I'm copacetic in general and have deep
understanding if my eyes cause a
soothing sort of aurora aura and aurora
it's not a word you're from what will
Rory is yeah I'm from there but if I
have a soothing aura about me that's
contagious it's because I've seen the
other side brother do I'm glad you said
this you've seen the other side I have
is it the other side of boring because
there have been really boring Brandon do
you meditate and just makes you boring
Brandon I am dealing with I'm dealing
with consciousness right now I'm more
conscious when you see my back ripple
and I pull myself up like a champ like a
chimp through 30 times fast while
talking to you
why wouldn't I give that to you as it's
a gif it's a gift it's a gift